[Applause]
Wow
so it is perhaps appropriate that on
Thomas Jefferson's birthday we bring to
you one of our most prestigious speakers
and one of Jefferson's cleverest
biographers professor Annette
gordon-reed is the one who definitively
cracked the case as our speaker on
Tuesday might have said on one of
American history's most complex and now
expunged
until now expunged stories which is the
relationship between the Jeffersons and
the Hemings is Professor Gordon Reid is
the Charles Warren professor of American
legal history at Harvard Law School and
a professor of history in the Faculty of
Arts and Science at Harvard University
she has a jaw-dropping list of honors I
will read you a few a fellowship from
the Detroit Dorothy and Louis B Coleman
center for scholars and writers at the
New York Public Library a Guggenheim
Fellowship a MacArthur Fellowship the
National Humanities medal and the woman
of power and influence award from the
National Organization for Women in New
York City she's written extensively on
both seen and unseen Americans including
a biography of Andrew Johnson and her
most recent book ad in paperback today
is most blessed of the patriarchs Thomas
Jefferson and the Empire of the
imagination so when it comes to
Jefferson as I said earlier we're very
fortunate to have dr. Gordon Reed here
for no one knows the public and private
Jefferson quite as well as she does the
story of the relationship between our
third president and his own slave is one
she first explored back in 1997 with her
book Thomas Jefferson and Sally Hemings
and American controversy she came to the
subject again more than a decade later
with her 2009 book the Hemings 'as of
Monticello an American family which won
both the National Book Award and the
Pulitzer Prize for history and it's this
book and this subject that bring us
together tonight and it's an important
topic and for some an uncomfortable
topic to be sure as the historian Joseph
Ellis said quote Thomas Jefferson is
often described his slaves at Mohnish
as my family a net gordon-reed has taken
that description seriously surely more
than Jefferson ever intended it is not a
pretty story but it is poignant bayaan
belief it is indeed and is also
wonderfully and touchingly told but then
those of us who know her and her work
would expect nothing less so ladies and
gentlemen please help me welcome to
great lives the wonderful Annette
gordon-reed
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much thank you it's
wonderful to be here I was in
Charlottesville earlier today for the
presentation of the Thomas Jefferson
medals one of my dear friends a little
better Lynch the former attorney general
received the medal for law and so I
stopped off in Charlotte field be able
to see that inside and that wonderful
building the Rotunda that has been
redone and is absolutely beautiful and
then I got in a car and I came here to
be with you today and I'm very very
happy to be here on a beautiful day
spring day and been able to enjoy the
hospitality of people here and the
beautiful beautiful campus this is
interesting for me because I'm sort of
in the middle of a book tour with my
co-author Peter oneth who helped me
write most bless of the patriarchs
Thomas Jefferson and the Empire the
imagination and we've been going around
together so it's flying solo is
interesting I was used to doing it
before but I've gotten used to having
him here but tonight is a hemming story
night and I'm glad to talk to you about
this my first book Thomas Jefferson and
Sally Hemings an American controversy I
thought was really about historians
about the way people wrote history and
particularly the way historians had
handled the story about whether or not
Thomas Jefferson had had children with
an enslaved woman Sally Hemings who
lived on his plantation Monticello I was
concerned about the practice of
listening to the stories of the white
family the legal white family
upper-class people
and dismissing the story of enslaved
people who talked about their life in
slavery about something that was as we
know now from the family stories of
african-americans and as we know now
from DNA testing I'm not talking about
Hemings testing but testing that
population geneticists have done on
African Americans across the country and
it pretty shows shows very much that the
kind of mixing that
what's going on at Monticello was going
on across the south and this was not
something that was rare and it was not
something that people talked about in
their letters but we could see it
visibly in the faces and the bodies and
the contour of the hairs hair of African
Americans all over the United States so
I was concerned about the the way of
dismissing the story of African
Americans and crediting the story of the
legal family and after my book came out
in 1997 and the DNA testing followed in
1998 that corroborated supported what it
was that I was suggesting in my first
book it occurred to me that one of the
reasons that it was easy to dismiss the
story of the Hemings family was because
people didn't know anything about the
Hemings family other than that there was
a scandal and they knew the name Sally
Hemings and they knew may have known the
name James Hemings of her brother who
was the chef but by and large people
didn't know that much about the family
and I was thinking that if I could tell
their story in a way that made people
feel that they had a stake in them that
it might give people pause in the future
about dismissing the story of enslaved
people I live in Manhattan and well most
I live partly in Manhattan partly in
Cambridge but when I'm in Manhattan it's
a big city crowded city and sort of an
anonymous City but when you meet
somebody if I meet somebody in the
neighborhood I immediately began to see
them after that know when you're
introduced to someone you see them all
the time you've been walking past them
before but you didn't know them once you
began to know them you notice their
children you notice when you don't see
them where you expect to see them they
become a part of you in a way you have a
stake in them and that's what I wanted
to do with the Hemings family was to try
to give people a stake in this family
now this is an interesting time to be
thinking about this because you may have
seen an article in The Washington Post
not long ago that talked about the fact
that Monticello now is redoing the room
the rooms where they think Sally Hemings
may have lived if you've been to
Monticello you know that I mean or any
kind of public museum like that it has
to pick a particular moment in history
to show because they can't show the
entire range of you know 50 years worth
of development of Monticello but this is
an area where they think Sally Hemings
lived and the story appeared in the
Washington Post as I said and it got a
lot of attention and I think the tour
that they're going to be doing who will
get a lot of attention now because she's
there but not like really there the idea
of actually having the room and having
it part of a tour and interpreting that
I think it's probably gonna cause you
know a lot of talk controversy talk and
that's what you want I mean that's what
a museum is supposed to be an
educational experience and you have to
have talk and controversy and discussion
in order to do it I mean that's that's
what you what you want but I thought
that or I was thinking about writing
this book that I wanted to do something
other than just focus on Sally Hemings
and in fact I was adamant that I was not
going to talk that much about her which
of course is crazy because she's the
pivotal part of the story right
obviously the family we know the family
because of the scandal oh because
because of the the story about Thomas
Jefferson and Sally Hemings so it was
unrealistic for me to think that I could
know wasn't gonna leave her out but I
wanted to de-emphasize her and then I
realized that didn't make any sense that
I had to be realistic about this
and understand the sort of pivotal role
that she played in her family and tried
to see the hemings's not just through
her just as her but see her as part of a
web of relationships that made the story
of Monticello how it made sense Thomas
Jefferson and Sally Hemings don't make
sense just as the two people they are a
part of
I said a web of relationships a her--let
his relationship with her brothers with
her mother with her sisters it flows
together if you think about it and when
I was working on the book at Fir my
first book I was a little puzzled by
Sally Hemings I was doing the sort of my
own version of a book tour then and
people would always ask me about her and
say well she was in Paris with Jefferson
and his daughters and her brother and at
one point you know when he's about to
come home the story is told that she did
not want to return with him because she
did not want to be reinstated and she
didn't want her children to be enslaved
and the question when Jefferson and
according to Madison Hemings his story
Jefferson promised her if she came back
home with him that she would have a good
life at Monticello and that her children
would be fully freed at 21 now in France
there was a possibility of becoming a
free person every person who filed a
petition for freedom in Paris at this
time had the petition granted so there
was a good chance that she and her
brother could have remained in Paris as
free people it would have been difficult
but people who ran away through swamps
and all kinds of hardships in the United
States had a difficult time to when they
ran away so the fact that was difficult
did not mean that it would have been
impossible or that she you know was
crazy to think this is something that
she that she could do but I was puzzled
and people always asked me when I went
around to give talks why did she come
back why would she come back to the
United States when she had a chance to
be a free person why would she not try
to get away from the the Jefferson
family and people had some ambivalent
feelings about her and I have to admit I
had ambivalent feelings about her as
well
while I was working on the first book
and because I was I was thinking mainly
about historians and what they had
written it wasn't focusing as much on
the Hemings family's story I was writing
about this controversy when I decided to
write the book about the hemings's as a
family and I began to flesh out the
individuals their particular role in the
family how they saw themselves how she
saw herself apparently in within this
web of relationships it began to make
sense to me she began to make much more
sense to me a 16 year old girl who has a
chance to be a free person but would be
in a foreign country we think her
brother James who was about 7 years
older than she would have been there for
support as well but she would have left
a family behind she would have left a
mother sisters and if you think about
the way women are today and even were
then certainly socialized to think about
family responsibilities to family then
it makes sense to me it made much more
sense to me why she would think that she
should come back to the United States
the other thing that is said in Madison
Hemings his recollections who talks
about his mother
in France she said he says that she
implicitly trusted Jefferson and that
was the one even more so than not coming
back that was the one that really gave
me pause because the question would be
and why would you do that
I mean I would construct him and
construct him as her enemy and see him
that way from my position writing in 19
1996 1997 when I was working on this
book well my first book and looking at
Sally Hemings and kind of judging her
implicitly trusting him it seemed a
dubious proposition to me but then
working on the Hemings as a Monticello
and seeing the family as a hold and
thinking about them as
whole learning about how Jefferson dealt
with them and how they dealt with him
learning how he took this family and
made them in some ways different than
other enslaved people they were not free
they were still enslaved but he treated
them differently from other people and I
looking back as a historian could say
you know all of those perks all those
things that you think are favors or
whatever you're still an enslaved person
and they knew that but if you imagine
yourself in that circumstance how
difficult it would be or what it how it
could affect you if someone was treating
you in a different way was telling you
in a sense that you're different than
those other people who have the same
legal status as you but are being
treated very very differently it might
affect the way you feel I mean one of
the things about being a scholar of
slavery and you're looking at these
looking at this this situation it's so
hard to imagine being in that position
it's but you have to remember as well
that you're dealing with people who are
human beings you're dealing with human
beings who are strong in some ways and
who are weak in other ways every kind of
personality that exists among whites
during that time period or Elliott or
now or whatever existed within the
enslaved community the system of slavery
was the overlay of their lives but they
were individuals with their own
personalities their own quirks their own
strengths and their own weaknesses that
played out within the context of this
system so once I began to think about
the Hemings family as a group and
understanding how Jefferson handled them
how in a way I don't want to use the
word co-opted because that's judgmental
it's very very easy from me from the
safety of now to talk about it perhaps
criticize people for the way they try to
make the best deals that they can for
their lives in
this really really oppressive system I
mean I I have the luxury of making that
kind of judgment but I don't want to do
it because I don't think it's fair the
thing is to try to do that I was trying
to do was to try to think about this
family as human beings within the
context of this particular system so I
had to start at the beginning
talking about the matriarch of the
Hemings family Elizabeth Hemings who was
the daughter of an Englishman and a
woman who was of African who was African
she may have actually been from Africa
or her parents could have been African
and she was born in Virginia Elizabeth
is therefore mixed-race she was owned by
a family
the Epps family an old family in
Virginia and a man named John Wayles
married into the Epps family had a
daughter with Martha Epps and who died a
couple of weeks after her daughter was
born he married twice
after that lost those two wives
and at some point took Elizabeth Hemings
as a concubine now Madison Hemings was a
man who gave his recollections about his
life at Monticello in 1873 and he said
that he was the son of Thomas Jefferson
and Sally Hemings and he's telling the
story of his family and and of his
grandmother she became the concubine of
John Wales and had six children by him
and the youngest of those children was
Sarah and Sarah was Sally the nickname
Sally was was given to her that I guess
Sally is the the nickname for Sarah and
John Wayles
has these six children his daughter with
Martha Epps who is also named Martha
that's one of the tough things about
this book out there only Martha and Mary
Polly and Patsy and I have a family tree
in it that I have to keep consulting to
figure out who is whom in here
but Martha grows
and she marries Thomas Jefferson when
John Wales dies the Hemings family and
135 other enslaved people come under the
ownership of John
excuse me of Martha and Thomas Jefferson
as the husband you know the Blackstone
quote you know the one you there's
marriage the husband and wife become one
and the one is him is the man he is he
is in control of this particular family
and lands
Martha brings they bring the Hemings
children to Monticello and install the
the women the women as the sort of
favored health servants of Martha the
men the boys they're actually boys
become servants to Jefferson Jefferson
had a manservant a man named Jupiter we
believe his name was Evans who men who
had served him or had been with him from
the time he was a little boy Jefferson
moves him out of that position and makes
Robert Hemings Sally Hemings as eldest
you know Wales brother his manservant
Robert is 12 at the time he's got to
figure out what kind of manservant he
could have been at age 12 he travels
with Jefferson he's with Jefferson in
Philadelphia when he writes the
Declaration of Independence so you get a
sense of this family melding together
not just Jefferson and and his wife
Martha but Martha's enslaved
half-siblings now we don't know very
much about Martha Wales Jefferson the
letters between Jefferson and his wife
were destroyed we think he destroyed
them even as an older man he was writing
people letters asking them if they had
any of her letters so they could take
them and destroy them this was not
uncommon among married couples to
because they didn't think that people
should know about the intimacies of
their relationship we don't know that
very much about her but it is sort of an
interesting thing that she brought her
brothers and sisters to live with her at
Monticello
and had them in her life on a daily
basis a lot of times in the slave
society when the master or his sons or
whatever had children with enslaved
women the women of the household were
really pretty ticked off about that and
sometimes would make them sell the
family members would be cruel to members
of the family they'd put them away
somewhere but it's interesting that she
brought them with her and brought them
and put them in the house so she's
around these women and Elizabeth who
comes as well on a daily basis so she
was not averse to having them around
when she dies in 1782 they are around
her death bed with her legal sisters
white sisters and sister-in-law and
Jefferson and they are the ones who tell
the story about Martha asking Thomas
Jefferson not to remarry and she says
they their story was that she did not
want she said that she did not want
another woman over her children there
wasn't like you know I want Thomas I
want you even in death or whatever
anything like that it was she may have
had some difficulty with her stepmothers
and she according to this story did not
want her children to have those problems
and he promised that he would not marry
again and he never did he she died when
he's about these 39 years old he dies
when he's 83 and he never remarried so
after her death
Jefferson is shattered he goes decides
to take a mission to Paris that admit
offered to him and he takes James
Hemings who was another person in the
story another person in the family who
most people who read the book many
people who read the book say that he is
their favorite member of the family
he Jefferson takes him to Paris to learn
how to become a chef Jefferson loved
French cooking
and he wanted a French chef for his for
Monticello and James was gonna fit the
bill he goes with to Paris with James
and his eldest daughter Martha another
Martha in this story and they're there
just the three of them for a few years
until Jefferson has what makes the
request that a younger daughter that he
has left behind be brought to him in
Paris and he asks that his daughter Mary
be accompanied by he said a careful
Negro woman such as Isabel and who's
talking about is Isabel Hearn who was
about 28 years old
instead Jefferson's sister-in-law who in
this convoluted story was actually Sally
hemings's half-sister to because she was
Jefferson's wife's sister and so she is
the aunt of the girl that she is taking
care of follow this along instead they
send Sally Hemings and Sally Hemings is
14 at this time and she is the guardian
or the companion of a nine year old girl
she's supposed to be the babysitter for
the nine-year-old girl they arrive in
London Abigail Adams who is there to
greet them is aghast she basically says
you know you got a kid looking after
another kid she's very very upset about
this they go on to Paris and at some
point and we don't know when Thomas
Jefferson and Sally Hemings begin and
here's the difficulty in that the
Washington Post article one of the
things that got people really really
really upset was that they used the word
relationship because what are we
describing here in the situation where a
person is enslaved and presumably can't
say no not presumably actually cannot
refuse consent do you call that a
relationship then we can talk about that
afterwards when you ask ask me questions
but it's difficult to know
to describe it because we're not talking
about a situation where they had sex and
had a kid and that's it what we're
talking about is a situation that starts
at some point in the end of the 1780s
and ends when he dies in 1826 so we're
talking about 38 years of whatever this
is and how do you discuss this how do
you how do you handle this particular
question and I try to handle it in the
book that's why the book is so long
because there's no easy answer there's
no to me there's no easy answer there
are people who take the position that
any sex between a master and an enslaved
woman is rape because we don't know that
the woman could refuse consent but then
you have this is the situation of Sally
hemings's sister an older sister not a
whale's sister Sally Hemings had some
half brothers and sisters as well who is
lives with a man on Main Street in
Charlottesville when Jefferson is away
in France and when Jefferson comes back
she asks to be sold to this man who
becomes her legal owner they live in
this house they have children and when
he dies he leaves them property and he
frees his children he never freezed the
woman he frees the children but
presumably she has control over the
house which is sort of an interesting
question how does an enslaved person
given or how are they given control of
the house but which tells you how law
operates there's law in the books and
there's law on the ground and as long as
the community acts like these that she
is the owner as long as the community
acts as if she is they referred to her
in later years as his common-law wife
but of course she couldn't have been his
common-law wife because she couldn't
have been his legal wife or that you
know she was enslaved so what do you say
about that situation so I look at
Sally's
situation I look at Mary situation and I
also talk about a woman named Celia
who's not from Charlottesville but she's
from Missouri and she was an enslaved
woman who killed her master after years
of sexual abuse you know he comes to the
house and you know to have sex with her
and she refuses and she hits him over
the head kills him takes his body burns
it up in her fireplace and then the next
morning asks his grandson she says I
have a lot of ashes in my um in my in my
fireplace would you help me clean it out
and unbeknownst to him this kid goes
he's basically you know throwing his
grandfather's ashes out back in the
woods
now CLU of course gets in trouble Celia
is you know she's tried for this and
strangely enough the white people many
of the white people in the community
were sympathetic to her they broke her
out of jail because they knew about the
way he had been abusing her but she's
brought back and eventually of course
she's executed but you look at these
three situations there's Mary is there a
difference between sell me to this
person so I could live with him and have
children and I'm gonna hit you of the
head and kill you and burn you up in a
fire and I mean do other other qualities
of those two women's lives exactly the
same it strikes me that they're not I
mean I can want to make a statement
about slavery and make a statement about
the the rape that happened to I think
most enslaved women's you know the more
common situation was Celia than Mary
obviously but if I'm writing about Mary
I can't
in order to make to my mind a political
point act as if I don't notice the
difference between those two situations
now what about Sally Hemings is she
closer to Celia
or is she closer to Mary and we're not
gonna have an answer to that because
Jefferson didn't write about the
unlike Celia who story who gets told
because she enters the legal world
there's a case and people are describing
what happened we don't know what Sally
Hemings felt about this all the only
action that we know that she took was
that she decided to come back with him
and she did but once she gets here she
is completely here that is to say
Virginia
she's completely under his control and
if at some point she didn't want to you
know take her job was to take care of
his rooms and his wardrobe essentially
and to sew and to look after her
children that's basically what she did
if she didn't want to have anything to
do with him she couldn't say no anymore
people have pointed out to me that
Jefferson's wife couldn't have said no
either once they got married because
there was no such thing as marital rape
law rules against marital rape until
well into the 20th century but he could
but he could not sell his wife and he
could have sold Sally Hemings and he
could have sold her her children or
their children now he didn't do that
and the children left Monticello as free
people but how do you handle these kinds
of things that's one of the things that
I sort of grapple with in the book and
it's a subject now that I have a feeling
Monticello is going to be dealing with
quite a bit now that they have decided
to do the room and will actually have
people they are talking about this
particular subject and and interpreting
her people will be forced to think about
her as a person so the second part of
the book really after I get through
talking about Elizabeth Hemings and
setting things up the second section of
the book is really about Sally Hemings
and the beginning of of this connection
relationship liaison whatever it is
we're going to call it with Jefferson
and then the third part of the book
really tries to do what I said I rigidly
was going to do and that is branch out
and talk about other members of the
Hemings family as much as possible if
been to Monticello you know the story of
of John Hemings John Hemings was the
master carpenter at Monticello and he's
responsible for some of the furniture
there that's on display even now for the
he did the floors he did the roof at
poplar forest for Jefferson he was also
a surrogate father of sorts to
Jefferson's sons Beverly Madison Eston
Hemings they were put under the tutelage
of John Hemings to learn how to become
carpenters and one of the things that I
I won't say discovered because I knew it
when I was writing my first book but I
didn't make anything of it because as I
said I wasn't really thinking about the
story of the Hemings is in the same way
Jefferson had a retreat popular forest
that's that he took to going to in his
retirement because when he retired it
seemed like the world descended on him
at Monticello and stayed for weeks at a
time and instead of saying you know you
should go he left and he left it too now
I'm leaving it to you and so he would go
to poplar forest and stay a lot it for
long periods of time and there were a
series of letters where he writes to his
overseer at poplar Forest and he says
I'm coming to popular forum I will be
arriving on such and such date I'm
bringing Johnny Hemings
and his two assistants or Johnny Hemings
and his apprentices he doesn't use their
names but his apprentices and his
assistants are either you know beverly
Merritt hair a Beverly Madison and estin
so he is coming with and he says the
rest of the Carpenters will come another
day so he's traveling with these boys
because they're boys at this time and
then young men to go out to popular
forest and spending large amounts of
time if you've ever been to popular
forest it's not a big place so he's
around them quite a bit and I hadn't
really thought about that that much
because you know you think of him
Madison Hemings and his recollection
says that Jefferson was uniformly kind
to everyone and to them but he was not
in the habit of showing them partiality
or fatherly affection so you read that
and you sort of think that he's you know
distant I mean I thought of sort of you
know sort of physical distance but these
letters suggest that they are together
quite a bit these people actually these
young men actually knew would have known
Jefferson very well because they spent a
good amount of time with him in in their
in his retirement so that kind of gave
me a different window to into Jefferson
and into the lives of the Hemings family
and how these connections actually in
some ways benefited other members of the
family the collateral members of the
family there's a story about another
James Hemings not the chef James Hemings
but his nephew because they may be they
name their children children after one
another too who gets beat by Jefferson's
overseer and he runs away runs away to
Richmond
Jefferson sends somebody to find him and
once he finds that he's found he tells
him to come back and Jamie says I'm not
coming back unless you promise me that I
can work with John Hemings that I don't
have to go back and work under the new
the overseer who had beat beat him
because Jefferson's artisans were not
under the control of the overseer they
answered to Jefferson not to not to the
overseer and Jefferson says okay you can
you know you come back you can work with
John Hemings and then Jamie decides he
doesn't want to come back at all and he
just doesn't come back and Jefferson
takes him off the slave rolls he
essentially lets him go
now Jane James Hemings this Jamie is
Sally hemings's nephew it's his wife's
half now
half-half nephew he's John Wells his
grandson that connection meant something
if James Hemings had been you know was
James Hubbard who was another enslaved
man at Monticello who ran away and
Jefferson had him brought back and he
kept running away and Jefferson he'd
come back and he would bring him back
and Jefferson actually had him whipped
and sold because he kept running away so
that see the difference between James
Hubbard who has no family connection to
Jefferson and James Hemings who has all
of these family connections and when he
runs away he tells Jefferson I'm not
coming back and Jefferson who says well
I'm not coming back unless you put me
under yeah
issues basically a condition and
Jefferson abides by it goes along with
it and then when he runs away and
doesn't come back at all Jefferson just
lets him go and he appears in other
records Jefferson is paying him later on
to be to get some instruments from him
or some scientific instruments from him
for Richmond so years later so he has
contacted the family he's just off the
slave rolls well that could only happen
because of a family connection he didn't
Jefferson didn't wouldn't take that
wouldn't accept that from another
another enslaved person so this
connection that to my mind when thinking
about it looking at my first book that
just seemed you know what is the purpose
of this why I mean why would she even
why would she come back what purpose
would it serve to do that you kind of
wonder if there was not some sense that
that was probably the best deal that she
might be able to get in life and she
would be with her family not necessarily
coming back for him but coming back to
the United States as a way of being with
family and in some ways having a
connection that protected her family in
some fashion we'll never know the answer
to this as I said because we don't have
Sally Hemings as letters but looking at
the family look at the things that
happened to
there is a story about this there's a
way of thinking about this that I did
not really didn't it didn't really make
as much sense didn't make much sense to
me when I was thinking about it the
first time now
the story ends not very well because
Jefferson dies bankrupt in 1826 he
doesn't I mean he has to sell that
things are sold to pay the debts
enslaved people are sold some of them
are bought back it's a very very murky
kind of situation but some members of
the Hemings family end up on the auction
block and I end the story of the Hemings
is not talking about Sally Hemings and
her children but talking about a man
named Peter Fawcett he's not a man at
the time he's a little boy who sold away
from his family and it takes many many
years before they are reunited
Peter Fawcett ends up in Ohio as a
minister and as a prominent caterer and
he does get reunited with his family
after a long after many many years he's
able to buy his freedom and I end with
that story because it shows you the real
the sort of tenuous nature of this
notion of privilege Peter Fawcett was
the grandson of Mary Hemings the person
who was living on on Main Street with
with her with with Thomas Bell the white
man and he described his life as a
little boy as privileged but the real
shot to him was when he was sold when
the thing that slavery was about came
brutally to his reality profit property
people as property who could be bought
and sold and that was a thing that was
that many members of the Hemings family
despite what
privileged Sally Hemings and her
children might have had they all lived
with the specter of the possibility that
that could happen because the law
construed them as property and Jefferson
construed them as property and that's
the difficulty that we have in thinking
about him in relation to this family and
thinking about Jefferson as a you know
as a person we could talk about that in
the question and answer period what do
you make of this situation the hemings's
are seen as privileged members of you
know people who lived on the mountain of
enslaved people on the mountain but they
were enslaved they couldn't leave
despite their talents about their
capabilities despite their capabilities
they were still legal property and
however Jefferson treated them however
better he treated them that was the
reality that shaped their lives and
that's the message that I that I got
most forcefully in thinking about this
family and writing about them and
spending so much time with them is to
think about the precarious nature of
their lives even under the power of a
person who thought of himself as
benevolent so with that I'm finished
[Music]
the questions the question-and-answer
period is always the best one
so across room with Kelly as well you
mentioned that sally was 14 when she
joined Jefferson in Paris mm-hmm how old
was Jefferson Jefferson was 30 years
older than she so he's 44 yes it's quite
an age span people that's one thing I
did a talk before like a middle school
students and people came to ask me that
asked me to come to talk to them about
and I thought how am I gonna do this
you know how I'm gonna do this to talk
to middle middle school students and of
course I shouldn't have worried because
I got there and people said well you
know they said kid said I don't know why
they're calling this an affair an affair
is when you were having you know sex
with somebody other than your your
husband or wife and I went yeah that
that's right they're actually quite
knowledgeable people and then I said
well and then they said well I said
what's the big deal here I said if she
would he's their master he can do what
he wants I said yes that's that's right
that's true and he said why do people
not see that and I said well you know
they have difficulty with it because
they don't like the idea of Jefferson
you know doing this and they said well
what other what are the problems and I
mentioned well you know they were not
the same race and so that bothered
people and and that didn't really get to
them and then one young girl raised her
hand and she said how old was she and I
said well she had her first baby when
she was 17 so she's probably about 16
years old you'd think the only evidence
of the beginning of sexual activities
that she had a baby when she was 17 when
I mentioned she would have been about 16
years old they went oh because they
began to look at how old they were and
counted up and think about it you know
the racial thing really didn't get to
them
you know the power story didn't really
get to them it was the age thing that
that gave them made them pause but the
age of consent in Virginia during this
time period was twelve and it was raised
though it was ten actually and then it
was raised to twelve in the 1820s so I
mean he wouldn't I mean Sally him a
sixteen year old or fifteen-year-old
girl would not have been thought of the
way we think of a fifteen that's a baby
you know is this a baby I mean you know
kids are you know we've prolonged
childhood I mean now to 35 you know
whatever it means it's it's it's it's
sort of gone on it's sort of dragging
this out quite a bit but then it
wouldn't have been but still I'm writing
this at the time that I was writing this
I had a teenage daughter and I'm like
you know you're pulling your hair out
just thinking about this but that's not
how they would have would have thought
about this situation
do you have some sense you've brought to
light something I was totally unaware of
this this age aspect you said you know
his man servant was someone who was 14 I
think you said so is there a sense that
Jefferson like surrounding himself at
that stage in his life with people who
were so young as a way to sort of be a
father figure or for some other reason
to have young people around him that he
could easily converse with or talk to or
you have an interplay with well I think
Robert is brought in because he'd
married Roberts I would again this is
this is the novelistic the novelist the
fake that you're the the wannabe novel
is coming out I think he probably made
Robert his manservant as a show of
solidarity with his wife this is his
wife's half-brother I I wonder about
Martha because Robert and James
we don't know Sally I mean Robert and
James could read and write and they
could evidently read and write as young
people and I wonder who taught them how
to read and write
you know it it's possible that there
that Martha could have done that I think
it's I could see a hand of Martha in
this this is totally speculative and you
would put this in a historical novel
I don't put this in you know you don't
have any were proving this but I think
Robert is attached to Jefferson because
he's married Roberts sister and I think
it's really important to keep that in
mind these these relationships other
historians would write about the Hemings
is in the past and would not they'd say
James or you know or a slave they might
use their name or not but I think it's
important to keep that relationship in
mind
bobert is what is Jefferson's wife's
half-brother and what better way for him
to be to get education to get you know
to see the world to see other things
than to be hanging out with Jefferson so
I don't know that he I don't think I
don't he's picking him because he's
young I think he's picking him because
of his connection to his wife who
evidently wanted her half siblings in
her household and to sort of give out
you know Goods and favors to those
particular people as opposed to others
yes it seems to me that you have tacitly
assumed that Jefferson is the father of
her children but you never said so as I
understand it he had brothers or a
brother who possibly and I'm not sure
about DNA does DNA say Jefferson Thomas
Jefferson or someone else so no DNA does
not say that's that's why I said the DNA
supported what I said it didn't it's not
it's not a paternity test the reason I
believe that it's Jefferson is not just
the DNA it's other information that I
compiled in my first book and it's the
totality of the circumstances and the
brother has no written connection to
Sally Hemings you can't I mean that's
not historical to say you know if you
have a situation where Jefferson's
friends are writing about it in their
diary people who visit Monticello are
writing about it in his letters the
stuff the names of the children they're
all named for his best friends and
favored relatives so it's it's the kind
of thing that a genealogist would do you
look at the totality of the
circumstances and then you put the DNA
on it when the family had you know the
family basically the Jefferson family
you know couldn't you know basically
made up a story about who was the father
of the children and the DNA killed that
so if they would have known that if it
was Jefferson's brother they would have
known that and they would have picked
him but they didn't know that there
would come a day when you could
differentiate between maternal relatives
and paternal relatives they picked the
wrong relative and that's what the DNA
says so know that the DNA test is not a
paternity test but it's the DNA and
other information that has been compiled
and that's what historians do I mean you
you know you you compiled information
and so and I that's my conclusion and
that the Foundation's conclusion at
Monticello and that's the story that
they that they tell now
I want to know about what oh the
president of the University of Virginia
ought to be able to quote Jefferson when
it's appropriate I mean I mean he's you
know I I you know I don't let the copy
out is this if it's you know every time
there's alternate side parking or
there's some kind of miss you know
missive that doesn't really have
anything to do with thing if you have to
bring Jefferson into it you know it's
it's you know whatever day and so
Jefferson would have said blah blah blah
I don't think that but I the Jefferson
said a lot of things that were terrible
but Jefferson said a lot of things that
were wonderful and if it's appropriate
to use his words I think they ought to
be used he was the founder of the
University of Virginia you can't pretend
that that didn't happen so yeah I think
Jefferson ought to be you can quote
Jefferson when it's an appropriate thing
to do I don't know maybe people who UVA
are getting tired as I said if it's some
sort of rope thing that you're doing for
no reason
but you can't you can't get rid of
Jefferson I mean you can't there are
things that you have to live with and
you deal with the problems the flaws you
deal with the good points and the bad
points but they're you know he's not if
people ask me about this all right you
know all the time and you know he's not
John Calhoun right not John I mean
there's a difference between a person
who you know helped found the United
States of America and a person whose
ideology
helped people think that they should
destroy the United States of America
that's a different type of person
altogether so I think I think we're
stuck with him you know I mean we got
the Declaration of Independence
you know the Library of Congress you of
West Point
you have the Jefferson grid you have
just on and on and on I mean he sort of
injected himself into all aspects of
life and you just have to deal with that
and I think it's a good thing to deal
with it because it helps you talk about
the most difficult aspects of American
life the best and the worst I mean I say
in the book that it's fitting to talk
about this story because Monticello is
where we've been the best and the worst
in one spot do one person and yeah so
yes president Sullivan should quote
Jefferson
when it's appropriate if it's not a pro
I mean you know I mean just to throw it
out there just for no reason but she
wouldn't do that so presumably she's
doing this for a reason and you can't
take him out of the out of the
University taught use it to talk I mean
Calhoun is not was not worth it I mean I
talked to people at Yale about this when
they were trying to decide what to do he
didn't occupy the same space at Yale
that Jefferson occupies at Virginia so
you know we could do without him and
they will do about calhoun they'll have
another they have another name for it
but the university is is Jefferson's
University you know your Hemings name
came from with regard to this family no
I don't we don't it's you know I've
tried to figure that out that was one of
the things that I was you know that I
tried to see I tried to see if there
were sort of in English antecedents to
it there Hemmings is in England but no
the captain who is supposed to be you
know captain Hemmings they mention him
but I don't know where he came from
I mean the antecedent nazar is the the
captain the the person who is the who
was the father of Elizabeth but I don't
know where I know I don't only put
anything beyond that I don't know his
first name so it's difficult to to track
down if you don't have a first name
there are hemings's but I haven't been
able to make the connection beyond just
the captain Hemings took my first
question so here's the second where are
you
disembodied voice do you
my last trip to Monticello the docent
there mentioned that upon Jefferson's
death that three of his three of Sally's
children were put in the carriage and
driven to DC and released without papers
assuming that someone told me that we
have to talk to them go ahead
well the assumption the assumption was
that they were so fair-skinned that they
could just blend into the population
just is that true it's sort of a mix of
stories that's mixed up here the eldest
son Beverly Hemings her eldest son
Beverly happenings and Harriet left
Monticello
to live as white people Jefferson put
Harriet on a stagecoach gave her money
and sent her away from Monticello he
says in his farm book that they ran away
but they left to go live as white people
Beverly left a couple of months before
Harriet and the thinking is you know he
went to prepare instead of sitting her
by herself or off by herself he left two
months earlier than Jefferson puts
Harriet on the stagecoach or has his
overseer do it gives her money and sends
her away
they went to live as white people we
don't know what happened to them because
of that Madison Hemings says that
Beverly married a woman in good
circumstances in Washington and had a
daughter she said Harriet married a man
and you know a man who was well-off as
well and had children multiple children
but they did not associate with the
family after a particular time because
when you pass into the white world you
can't keep going to see your you know
relatives who were not passing Beverly
is described at one point as having
ascended a hot-air-balloon in Petersburg
I tried tracking that down I mean I went
to the but I found a record of a balloon
ascension during the time
you know in the 1830s but I haven't been
able to find anything else about him I'm
doing a second volume of the Hemings
family story so I'm gonna try to figure
that one out
people periodically appear claiming to
be the descendants of Beverly and
Harriet but we haven't been able to
confirm that so the two eldest leave
they don't want papers because if they
have papers people know that they were
enslaved and if they were enslaved that
means they're part black and they
couldn't live as white people they were
actually by Virginia law white the law
in Virginia at that time was that if you
were 7/8 white you were white the
one-drop rule is something is a product
of the 20th century so technically they
were white people but the difference
between technical white this is an
actual whiteness that people had known
it would have been you know a problem
for them so the two eldest live as white
people the two youngest are freed in
Jeffersons will and they stay with their
mother until she dies and then they
leave and go to Ohio the youngest or in
estin at some point finds it really
difficult for his family in in
Chillicothe Ohio where they had settled
and he he was there are stories written
about him because he made his living as
a violinist in Ohio and their stories
about his daughter's piano recitals and
so forth but Ohio began to crack down on
blacks and he at some point decides to
take his family and he moves to Madison
Wisconsin he changes his name from Eston
Hemings to Eston Hemings Jefferson or eh
Jefferson and the children changed their
names to Jefferson and they live as
white people and they tell a story that
when people ask them are you related to
Jefferson they say oh you know we're
related to a Jefferson uncle or
Jefferson you know so a collateral
because the everybody knew that
Jefferson had
legitimate white sons so that's their
family's story for two generations they
keep the story of Hemings and Jefferson
but the grandchildren because they're
want to be white they don't tell them
about that and they lose the story of
Sally Hemings and they lose the story of
Thomas Jefferson too
it's better better than being a
descendant of Thomas Jefferson if you're
part black it's better to forget that
than to you know live as a as a black
person with all the the limitations that
would be on you so that family loses its
story and that is that family line that
gave the DNA for the testing that was
done in in 2008 they had not known I
mean 1998 they didn't know until the 70s
they had a son who kept trying to do his
family history and they were a long line
of Princeton graduates and they he
couldn't get past a certain point and it
wasn't until farn Brody wrote her book
and had Madison Hemings his
recollections in the back of him that
they realized
Eston they had thought his name was SD
and they couldn't figure this out that's
when they realized that there was a
connection so Madison Hemings was the
only one who family remained in the
black community although some of his
children passed passed into whiteness as
well so the story is partly true Beverly
and Harriet leave before Jefferson dies
so it's not upon his death that they get
put in a stagecoach only one is in the
stagecoach Harriet is in the stagecoach
this is in 1822 before Jefferson dies
and the two youngest children are freed
in his will stay in Charlottesville a
time and then go off to Ohio
doctor thanks so much for your research
do we have any knowledge I'm over here
do we have any knowledge of the
relationship between the hem and see him
and cease and the rest of the slaves on
Monticello was there a lot of resentment
with the other house slaves of the field
slaves about the special unique
relationship or did they know of it were
they aware of it well you know it's
interesting because the people who have
done that last point that you're making
did they know of it the people who are
doing this project at Monticello called
getting word where they're talking to
all the people who were descendants of
people enslaved at Monticello
say that the Hemings story actually kept
was vivid to people who were not members
of the Hemings family and it was a
reason to remember Monticello
so even when they're talking to people
in a different family descendants they
can't they knew this story and talked
about it so it was something that people
knew and it was something that people
Jefferson's neighbors knew because they
talked about it I mean look at their let
they're talking about it in their
letters Jefferson Jefferson's grandson
Thomas Jefferson Randolph said that it
was a source of bitter jealousy that he
claimed that the other people down the
mountain other non Hemings people were
jealous of the Hemings is well that's it
because they were so close to the
Jeffersons well you know that was just
his interpretation it could well have
been that they thought that the Hemings
is were co-opted I mean of course Jeff
Randolph would think oh you know they're
jealous because these people get to hang
around us that probably was not the
answer the pie didn't want to hang
around with him it could have been that
they thought who do you think I mean
they would may have been resentful and
not jealous of them but saying who do
you think you are essentially you are
you have been co-opted by these by these
people
so that's the only hint of any kind of
enmity that might be between them but
the other you know the other indications
is that people did cooperate
I mean there's no reason to think that
they actually you know hated them but
I'm just the only comment that we have
about this comes from Jeff Randolph and
you really do have to be careful in
looking at the words of you know the
family the legal family who owns these
people to take their word for what what
is going on there and their
interpretation of it there's no reason
to think beyond that that they the loved
or hated members so they have made
family dr. Gordon read on this subject
that is never less than fascinating and
controversial so before we say goodnight
and thank her I want to remind everybody
that dr. Cordray will be signing copies
of her book in the lobby there will also
be copies of Courtney's parting gift by
our local historian available for there
and I also want to thank dr. Crowley for
me it's an exceptionally awesome year
for me my first year here Barry
Washington so thank you for much for
that and please help me thank and neck
ordinary
[Applause]
[Music]